faire du cirque et glisser dans ses
chaque été comme de nombreuses communes
yvelinoise mantes-la-jolie propose à ses
habitants une trentaine d'animations
sportives du locaux vides et cette
situation sanitaire
beaucoup de familles ne partent pas
comme comme normalement on doit partir
en vacances et du boulet beaucoup de
familles qui restent et d'où la
participation de ces jeunes à ces
activités
les premiers jours il y avait à peu près
trois mille 3000 si son gamin mais à
venir un jeune contrer mais avec la
canicule et ce qui se passe ça baisse un
petit peu il en est à peu près à 606 120
gamins jour cet été la commune a répondu
à un appel à projets pour son village
d'activités la ville a reçu 22 mille
euros de l'état auquel s'ajoute un
soutien du département
c'est aussi de une action éducative
puisque ça tombe d'enfants pour certains
ou des difficultés à suivre les cours
pendant le confinement donc il ya un
continuum quelque part qui peut
s'effectuer
pas forcément de manière identique dans
tous les quartiers apprécié l'initiative
des villes de de déployer telle ou telle
activité aux mureaux il ya un très gros
chantier d'insertion qui est d'ailleurs
déployé mis en place avec des crédits
importants 1 70 mille euros de l'état 30
millions d'euros sont répartis dans
toute l'île de france une trentaine de
communes yvelinoise bénéficient de ces
aides